SEVEN.
TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
♫
♫ ♫
>> Tucker: A GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IF YOU’VE BEEN SITTING IN FRONT
OF THE TV THE WHOLE NIGHT AND
WATCHING THE UNFOLDING PAGEANT,
YOU KNOW THAT MICHAEL FLYNN WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE SENTENCED TONIGHT
FOR THE CRIME OF LYING TO
WHITE HOUSE AGENTS IN HIS FAMOUS
INTERVIEW.
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS YOU
PROBABLY ALREADY HEARD ABOUT,
NONE OF THEM VERY SIGNIFICANT IN
THE COSMIC SCHEME OF THINGS,
THAT SENTENCING HAS BEEN
POSTPONED UNTIL THE NEW YEAR.
WE WILL BRING YOU THE DETAILS
WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
IN THE MEANTIME THOUGH WE
THOUGHT WE WOULD SEIZE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE STOCK OF ALL
THAT WE HAVE LEARNED.
MICHAEL FLYNN BEING THE FIRST
TARGET OF THE MOLAR
INVESTIGATION.
THAT WAS ALL THE WAY BACK AT THE
BEGINNING OF LAST YEAR, 2017.
IT HAS BEEN JUST ABOUT TWO YEARS
ALMOST.
AND IT’S NOW PRACTICALLY ITS OWN
AGENCY OF GOVERNMENT.
THERE COULD BE MORE ABOUT WHAT
WE COULD FIND WERE A HALF A
DOZEN SEPARATE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATIONS NOW BEING
CONDUCTED BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THAT DOESN’T COUNT THE SEPARATE
CONGRESSIONAL INCREASE OF FOUR
OR FIVE, WHO KNOWS, AND THEN
NEARLY 100% OF THE ATTENTION OF
THE RUSSIANS SPENT A TOTAL OF,
THE NEWS AGENCIES IN WASHINGTON.
LET’S CHECK THE MATH.
$4,700 ON GOOGLE ADS.
WE ALSO HAD JEROME CORSI AND
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS, PEOPLE YOU
HAD NEVER HEARD BEFORE, THAT
LIKELY DID SOMETHING BAD LIKE
MISREMEMBERING DATES OR EMAILS
ALTHOUGH APPARENTLY NONE OF THEM
EVER SPIED FOR ANYBODY.
WE HAVE ALSO LEARNED THAT -- AND
PEOPLE ARE NOT NOTING THIS BUT
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE WORTH
POINTING OUT, VIRTUALLY EVERY
ISSUE THAT LED VOTERS REMAINS AS
OF NOW UNRESOLVED AND IN SOME
CASES NOT EVEN ADDRESSED.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE THE DECLINE
OF THE AMERICAN MIDDLE CLASS,
THE DROP OF LIFE EXPECTANCY AND
THE OPIOID CRISIS, AND THE
GLOBAL DOMINANCE OF CHINA, THE
QUAGMIRE IN AFGHANISTAN,
INFRASTRUCTURE, HEALTH CARE
COSTS, YOU KNOW, THE LITTLE
THINGS.
THE NEWS ANCHORS HAVE NOT HAD
TIME TO TELL YOU ABOUT ANY OF
THAT BECAUSE THEY ARE TOO BUSY
SHOUTING SELF RIGHTEOUSLY ABOUT
MICHAEL FLYNN, HE LIED TO.
HE LIED TO.
THEY COME BY CONTRAST, NEVER
LIE.
UNLIKE MICHAEL FLYNN, WHO LIED!
SO THERE HAS BEEN A COST TO OUR
RUSSIA FIXATION.
HOW DID EVERYBODY IN AMERICA
WITH AN IVY LEAGUE EDUCATION
SIMULTANEOUSLY GO INSANE IN THE
SPACE OF A SINGLE YEAR?
WAS THERE SOME KIND OF MASS
POISONING, WAS ERICA CHISHOLM?
DID IT HAPPEN IN MEDIEVAL
FRANCE?
WE WILL LET HISTORIANS SORT THAT
OUT, BUT ALL WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN
IS THAT THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
HAVE LOST IT, THEY REALLY HAVE.
IF YOU DON’T BELIEVE IT, LISTEN
TO THEM EXPLAIN THE INTRICACIES
OF THE RUSSIA CONSPIRACY.
IT’S SO COMPLEX AND RIDDLED WITH
CONTRADICTIONS, IT SOUNDED LIKE
A CONTRADICTION.
TO THEM, RUSSIA IS THE
TOUCHSTONE, THE COMPREHENSIVE
THEORY OF EVERYTHING.
IT REALLY COULD HAVE BEEN ANY
NIGHT ON CABLE NEWS.
NBC, CNN, TAKE YOUR PICK.
WE HAPPEN TO BE WATCHING AROUND
11 AND WE ARE BRINGING THAT.
IT’S CALLED THE 11TH HOUR.
UP MALCOLM NANCE IDENTIFIES
HIMSELF AS A 35 YEAR VETERAN OF
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE WORK.
HIS MOST RECENT BOOK IS CALLED
THE PLOT TO PACK AMERICA.
THE SECOND MAN YOU ARE ABOUT TO
SEE IS BRIAN WILLIAMS WHO OF
COURSE NEEDS NO INTRODUCTION.
HE WAS AN ANCHOR OF THE NBC
NIGHTLY NEWS WHEN THAT MEANT
SOMETHING.
HE IS WIDELY REGARDED AS A GOOD
GUY BY THE PEOPLE WHO KNOW HIM
AND HE IS IN WASHINGTON THOUGHT
OF AS ONE OF THE SMARTEST PEOPLE
IN THE NEWS BUSINESS.
THE POINT IS, THESE ARE NOT
KOOKS ON LATE-NIGHT RADIO, THEY
ARE CONSIDERED HIGHLY IMPRESSIVE
PEOPLE.
WILLIAMS OPENS THE SEGMENT BY
EXPLAINING THAT RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION TEAMS HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO DEFY AMERICA.
THEY COMMENT ON THAT PROPOSITION
AND NANCE SAYS THAT THIS: >>
WHAT RUSSIA HAS DONE HERE AND
WHERE THE TRUE BRILLIANCE OF
THIS INTELLIGENCE OPERATION
COMES FROM IS A WAY BACK IN THE
EARLY 2000s, THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY CONDUCTED A STRATEGIC
STUDY AND STARTED CARRYING OUT A
DISINFORMATION PLAN IN WHICH
THEY SAID THAT INSTEAD OF
TEARING OUT KINETIC WARFARE
AGAINST YOUR ENEMIES, THE BEST
THING WE CAN DO IS CREATE A
DISINFORMATION AND FRAME AROUND
THAT NATION, TO THE POINT WHERE
OVER TIME AS WE ARE CONSTANTLY
TEARING THEM APART AND FEEDING
THEM WITH FALSE INFORMATION,
THEY WOULD ACTUALLY WELCOME AND
INVASION.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND HERE.
THIS IS WHAT WE IN THE NEWS
BUSINESS CALL, "NEWS."
SO FOR YEARS THEY’VE BEEN
BUILDING A DISINFORMATION FRAME
AROUND THE UNITED STATES.
HOW DOES IT MANAGE TO BRAINWASH
AN ENTIRE POPULATION SO
THOROUGHLY THAT THEY WELCOME A
FOREIGN INVASION?
THAT’S GOT TO BE THE MOST
POWERFUL MIND CONTROL DEVICE OF
HUMAN HISTORY.
MORE DETAILS PLEASE.
THIS IS A PART OF THE INTERVIEW
WHERE THE ANCHOR POLITELY
INTERRUPTS THE GUEST AND ASKED
THEM TO EXPLAIN WHAT HE IS
TALKING ABOUT.
BUT WILLIAMS DOES NOT DO THAT.
HE JUST LETS MALCOLM NANCE KEEP
TALKING.
>> SO RUSSIA HAS DONE THAT TO
THE UNITED STATES, AND IT BEGAN
WAY BEFORE 2016.
THE EARLIEST REFERENCES I HAD
WITH RELATION TO DONALD TRUMP
SHOWS THAT IT STARTED BACK IN
2011, WITH MARIE ABU TINA AND
THE NRA CONTACTS, CONTACTS WITH
THE FUNDAMENTALIST CHRISTIAN
RIGHTS.
IT RUSSIA WAS PUSHING THESE
DISINFORMATION TEAMS THEN, AND
THAT WAS THE RUSSIAN INTERNET
SEARCH AGENCY WHICH BUILT ALL OF
THESE MEMES AND TROPES WHICH
BECAME THE CRUISE MISSILES OF
FAKE NEWS AND DISINFORMATION
DESIGNED TO DO WHAT IT DID
TODAY.
TAKE ONE-THIRD OF THE
UNITED STATES POPULATION AND
MAKE THEM REFUSE TO BELIEVE WHAT
THEY SEE BEFORE THEIR VERY EYES
AND THEY MAY HAVE ELECTED A
PRESIDENT IN THE PROCESS.
>> Tucker: HOLY SMOKES.
THIS IS A TSUNAMI OF NEWS.
IT TURNS OUT THAT DONALD TRUMP’S
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA BEGAN
YEARS BEFORE ANY OF US
SUSPECTED, WAY BACK IN 2011.
HERE’S THE CONFUSING PART.
BY ALL OUTWARD APPEARANCE, TRUMP
WAS STILL A LIBERAL.
HE ENDORSED GUN CONTROL, IT WAS
ALL A COVER, A SOPHISTICATED
RUSE, AS MALCOLM NANCE REVEALS.
TRUMP WAS IN FACT BUSY PLOTTING
WITH THE NRA, CHRISTIAN
FUNDAMENTALISTS AND THE ALTAR
RIGHT.
KEEP IN MIND THIS WAS YEARS
BEFORE THERE WAS SUCH A THING AS
THE ALTAR RIGHT, BUT THIS IS HOW
STEALTHY THIS OPERATION WAS.
MALCOLM NANCE HAS EXPLAINED
THINGS TO RUSSIAN BRAINWASHING,
ONE-THIRD OF THE U.S. POPULATION
CAN NO LONGER PERCEIVE REALITY.
NOW WHAT WOULD YOU DO IF
SOMEBODY REPEATED THOSE EXACT
SAME WORDS TO YOU ON A CITY BUS?
HE WOULD LIKELY BE WORRIED AND
AT THE VERY LEAST WOULD PROBABLY
SWITCH SEATS.
WILLIAMS DIDN’T SEEM TO CONSIDER
WILLIAMS DIDN’T SEEM TO CONSIDE CONSIDER, AND WILLIAMS ASKED HOW
CONSIDER, AND WILLIAMS ASKED HOWTHE RUSSIANS COULD’VE PULLED OFF
THE RUSSIANS COULD’VE PULLED OFF
AN OPERATION THIS EXTENSIVE
WITHOUT THE WILLING HELP OF
AMERICAN -- THIS AIRED VERBATIM
LAST NIGHT ON MSNBC.
WATCH.
>> THEY HAVE PLAYED ON THE
THEMES OF FAR RIGHT CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS, AND THE JOHN BIRCH
SOCIETY, A SIDELINE GROUP.
THEY HAVE AMPLIFIED RACISM TO
THE POINT WHERE THE ALTAR RIGHT,
STEVE BANNON’S OWN CREATION OF
GAMERS, IS NOW A WHOLLY-OWNED
SUBSIDIARY OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND OUR BELIEVERS IN DAVID DUKE,
THE NEO-NAZI AND ROBERT SPENCER
THE KU KLUX KLAN, DAVID SPENCER,
OF THE PHOBIA, TO THE POINT -- A
OF THE PHOBIA, TO THE POINT -- D
OF THE PHOBIA, TO THE POINT -- T
OF THE PHOBIA, TO THE POINT -- I
OF THE PHOBIA, TO THE POINT -- S
OF THE PHOBIA, TO THE POINT -- R
OF THE PHOBIA, TO THE POINT -- P
OF THE PHOBIA, TO THE POINT -- T
OF THE PHOBIA, TO THE POINT -- S
OF THE PHOBIA, TO THE POINT -- O
HOW THEY WENT AFTER TO SUPPRESS
THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTE AND
THERE WAS NO DOUBT IN MY MIND OR
ANYBODY ELSE’S IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE THAT
DOESN’T BELIEVE THAT IT TOOK
AMERICAN CITIZENS TO ASSIST THEM
AND REALLY GETTING DOWN TO WHERE
THESE VOTERS WERE NEEDED TO BE
SUPPRESSED.
>> Tucker: IN CASE YOU WEREN’T
TRANSCRIBING THAT AS WE WATCHED,
LET ME BOIL THAT DOWN.
IT INCLUDES A BEWILDERING ARRAY
OF FIGURES INCLUDING THE JOHN
BIRCH SOCIETY, KKK, DAVID DUKE,
PEOPLE WHO PLAY ONLINE
VIDEO GAMES, STEVE BANNON, A
RELIGIOUS BLOGGER NAMED ROBERT
SPENCER, AND OTHERS.
COLLECTIVELY THEIR GOAL WAS NOT
TO SELECT DONALD TRUMP BUT TO
HURT AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
WHY WOULD RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE
DO THAT?
IF YOU HAVE TO ASK, YOU ARE
PROBABLY WORKING FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN, TOO.
SO SHUT UP.
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT ALL
OF THIS IS COMPLETELY INSANE AND
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
ANY OF IT.
WORSE THAN THAT, IT’S
IRRESPONSIBLE.
SOME LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE,
THEY GO TO SLEEP WORRIED ABOUT
THE INVISIBLE DISINFORMATION
THAT SURROUNDS OUR COUNTRY AND
THEY WILL WAKE UP A LITTLE MORE
CONVINCED THAT ANYONE WHO
DISAGREES WITH THEM IS A TOOL OF
A FOREIGN POWER.
BECAUSE THAT IS THE REAL MESSAGE
HERE, THERE IS NO OTHER SIDE OF
THE DEBATE.
HIS ONLY RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA.
A CERTAIN SORT OF FRAGILE
LIBERAL, THAT IS PROBABLY
COMFORTING TO KNOW BUT IT IS A
LAW, A LIE.
NEWS ANCHORS EXIST TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST NUTTY CLAIMS LIKE THESE.
BRIAN WILLIAMS BOUGHT THEM
COMPLETELY.
>> MALCOLM NANCE, THIS IS WHY WE
ASK YOU ALL THE TIME TO COME ON
THIS BROADCAST.
SCARY STUFF, BUT IT NEEDS TO BE
SAID AND NEEDS TO BE HEARD.
THANK YOU SIR, SO MUCH, FOR